a question here Rob from lose which i
think is in the UK it asks you and
others have talked about the need to
stop FGM within a generation do you
really think you can do it Kathy well
there's a goal that the UN is set to
eliminate it by 2015 which is the date
for the Millennium Development Goals I
don't think there's any reason we
shouldn't be trying for that that's
that's far enough away that we could
really do a concerted effort and frankly
it's going to take a glove campaign you
know we need a global campaign for girls
this ought to be right front and center
at the beginning of it so I think it's
doable there's a there may be a parallel
with China in that foot binding existed
for hundreds and hundreds of years and
various points I think in the ten long
Emperor some of it it may have been
fourteen long but that foot binding was
actually punishable by exile on the part
of the parents at zero effect I mean it
various points was banned no impact and
then early in the 20th century really
remarkably quickly it disappeared and it
went from a perception on the part of
parents that if they didn't bind their
daughters Feith it'd be hard for her to
marry to a perception that if they bound
her feet it'd be harder for her to get
married and it you know I guess the
question is one Emperor changed the rule
it was really a bottom-up social
movement it led by led by elites from
within the country part of this sense of
Awakening and supported by outsiders to
some degree but but really led from
within push from within so I guess the
you know the question is how we can
replicate that and whether groups like
host an are indeed whether this is the
next sort of foot-binding analogy so
that the change once it comes in which
tipping point heavens very very quickly
I just want to come back to that point
Kathy made at 2015 um I wish I shared
your optimism Kathy I just feel that
here talking about solutions we seem to
know what works we know this model is
there we know about the respect we have
to give to communities and many many
local NGOs and civil society
organizations are working on the ground
and you know to pay tribute to all of
those small organizations really at
danger as well one of the women who's
contacted me through this campaign Lucy
maschera who said you know go forth and
speak at Davos about this and her story
once she started speaking out within her
community she was raped she was beaten
she was tied to a tree she was jailed
she's luckily living now in the US but I
think what we need to see is how we can
in the next five years if that is true
take this to scale I'm using the
language of Davos there but really you
know what is preventing us if we know
how to make things change um why can't
we put this into place is it a funding
issue is it a global awareness issue
what what needs to happen what are the
levers that we can pull if we were here
sitting here saying actually this is to
intractable this is too difficult we're
not going to address this issue fair
enough but we're all sitting here in
vehement agreement that this is a severe
human rights abuse a child rights abuse
or women's rights abuse we've got a
solution what can we do